dairy farmer David McCoy is out early
milking the cows with his son Stephen
Irish milk and butter sell well abroad
but brexit could change that and hit
McCoy's livelihood hard
and Senator David McCoy took over his
father's farm 30 years ago back then
there were just five cows now there are
70 the herd brings in almost 15,000
euros a month in addition to his farm in
the Republic of Ireland David McCoy owns
land north of the border just two
kilometres away
if the water breaks it I don't know if
that would continue if we couldn't
export our slurry and get our crop back
from it well then
survivability would be very slim the
border between the United Kingdom and
the Republic of Ireland runs through the
meadow and of course it will be the e
use external border if and when brexit
occurs this is the border here where
this wire is lined this edge southern
ireland this side here is northern
ireland if they the border a was closed
then we wouldn't fit access the forage
that would get from this farm so a it
certainly leave us we'd have to downsize
our herd this is County Fermanagh in
Northern Ireland John Sheridan is a
sheep farmer
his sheep do the gardening in these
upland Moors for that Sheridan gets
subsidies from the EU in summer he can
let the Sheep out to pasture and doesn't
have to worry about them too much he
sells the lambs at the local livestock
market the meat is then exported to the
European Union they want to get these
loans now in the breaks of situation on
a hard situation to Europe by the time I
pay the tariffs and by the time I get
them there I'm only going to achieve two
hundred and twenty five cents I can I
can hardly afford to produce them at
four year old thanks very much
let alone achieve gender than 35 cents
if that's gonna happen it's hard brexit
these sheep graphic up native sheridan
relies on the EU market for him brexit
will be disastrous between 40% of our
lamb travel size so the million
breathing use in the north here that's
around 300 350 250 thousand lambs in the
years Sheridan along with other farmers
local business people and politicians
set up an action group called border
communities against brexit they've
demonstrated in Belfast and at the
border they want special status for
Northern Ireland and the border to
remain open in July the European
Parliament awarded border communities
against brexit for 2017 European
citizens prize this bridge in Belko
straddles the border hundreds of trucks
cross each day locals on both sides say
they don't want to see barriers and
barbed wire like in the bad old days
during the Northern Ireland conflict for
me to go to Bell cou I had to go through
semi-permanent checkpoint just along the
border from the British Army then I had
to go through an Irish Army checkpoint
then I had to go through an Irish police
checkpoint which was guarded by an Irish
army then I had to go through a southern
customs then I had to go through
northern customs and all while that was
being monitored by
a british police station with antennas
and cameras on it so that's what I had
to that's how I got through the border
others experienced the border
differently Tom Eliot is an Ulster
Unionist as a former British soldier he
patrolled the heavily guarded border
three decades ago obviously was a very
very significant terrorist campaign and
in the area from Anna the bein
terrorists were the Provisional IRA and
they were murdering people shooting
people planting bombs he remains deeply
mistrustful Eliot was against brexit but
has accepted it will happen as a
unionist his loyalties are with Britain
I won't be much part of that much bigger
economic community than we would of who
we were in an All Ireland state so I'm
clearly a unionist any special status
for Northern Ireland was certainly waken
the Union of the United Kingdom
the milk is being picked up at david
McCoy's farm the quality of the milk is
checked regularly if it meets EU
standards he gets a bonus on the price
he's one of a thousand farmers whose
milk is processed at the Lac Patrick
cooperative dairy for David McCoy the
European Union has been good for dairy
farmers on both sides of the border